这是我们用AI给OPPO翻译的X9 Ultra 做的广告, 全程没有视拍, 也不需要模特, 而且非常真实
我是如何做的人呢? 一起先看看成片
"This plan might not pass, you need to be prepared"""This plan is very good"
Maybe it's the quiet that belongs only to you, after the hustle
"Timeline""How's your doing now?"
Maybe it's that soft, tender voice saying "Mom" after a long day of exhaustion
"Haselblad in your pocket"
"These moments won't replay, but we keep them close to where the heart lives"
"Find X9 Ultra, Hasselblad in your pocket"
"What you can't bear to forget, it remembers"
这是我制作使用的画布,大家可以看到一些生成效果和设计
简单揭闭一下流程,我基本上是先brief和剧情,把自己当作广告导演
然后再根据想象的剧情去设计相应的分镜头图片,先出图再做视频
最后甚至我用AI做了音乐,然后再配音和剪辑
整个流程其实并不复杂的,但是需要落地想法和时间
点赞高的话,我再做一些创作思路和幕后分享,感谢您的关注